well you know when I first signed up to
play Loki Marvel and Disney weren't
working together and then the first time
I came down here was to for the Avengers
and what I love is is that now that
these kind of Marvel characters are
iconic for their own reasons but also
Disney you know there's such enthusiasm
and passion and for storytelling in a
very particular way so here we are in
Disneyland it's amazing to be to be here
and know that those the crowd out there
were wonderful they gave us such a warm
reception it was really cool
well it's a new twist it's a new
iteration it's a new roll of the dice
it's a new game of poker you know for
him because he the god of mischief
that's his Monica that's his epithet he
lives for wickedness and he basically
you find him at the beginning of the
film very deep in the darkest recesses
of Asgard and there is a enormous kind
of just a very great threat on the state
of peace in Asgard in the universe which
is which comes in the form of Malekith
and the Dark Elves played by Christopher
Eccleston and the only person who can
help for better or for worse is Loki
kind of like the a-team if you have a
problem and if no one else can help and
if you can find it maybe you can hire
something like that
yeah yeah I mean I'm I'm thrilled to be
here for a Disney animation film that's
that's why I'm so excited about and I'm
playing a role in the pirate fairy and
it's about Tinker Bell and the fairies
have Neverland and they live in Pixie
Hollow and there's one fairy who who
leaves that the sort of safety of their
community and goes to hang out with the
Pirates of skull rock in the season
Neverland and I play one of the Pirates
white so that's super fun basically
when I was a child my sisters and I and
my cousin's used to write plays in the
summer for my parents and we it was just
a you know this is in the in the years
before Xbox and Playstation and all that
stuff so we just wrote we just played
and then and I was always the bad guy
for some reason so nothing's changed and
I think I'm pretty sure he played hook
at one point we did a version our own
version of Peter Pan
which I think involved this swimming
pool like my cousin's had a swimming
pool on a holiday and there was a pool
it's amazing I mean Captain Hook for me
is is an iconic character that I you
know I saw the first one in the first
Peter Pan the Disney Peter Pan and then
Dustin Hoffman playing hook in Steven
Spielberg's film and I saw Sir Ian
McKellen play hook on stage at the
National Theatre so to be part of the
code a legacy of this amazing
Captain Hook's is a huge honor and a
thrill for me
yeah I think it's sort like for the
whole family you know it's something
that it's got lots of squash and a lot
of buckle and a lot of swinging from
ropes and and I think there's something
just intrinsically really fun about
pirates
and-and-and the girls was certainly
loved all the fairy stuff but hopefully
they'll love the pirate stuff too
you